hey everybody and welcome to an
unbelievably cool wild ride with steo I
really really feel strongly that I've
never been more Blown Away by the
coolness of one of our guests like I was
with ti tip and man is he impressive
with the movies and the music and the
comedy and the business and the
construction and the cars and the I mean
dude building all these housing projects
for for um people who need help I mean
the guy is just unbelievably awesome and
uh you know very candid too he didn't
shy away from anything he he uh he's
just awesome check it
out people of the Universe I bring to
you tip was that it yeah all right let's
catch you on the mic all right um so
dude we are parked outside of the world
famous Laugh Factory Comedy Club in West
Hollywood California on the Sunset Strip
and you're getting ready to go on stage
and do standup comedy uh I'm getting
ready to go inside um I I don't know if
I'm going to be on this show or or or
the N the 9:00 show but I will at some
point in time tonight whenever the time
uh presents itself I'll be doing stand
up good man say and you've been um
touring doing standup for the last year
and a half is that right uh it'll be two
years on January
27th dude it's Epic Man have you always
been interested in doing comedy or is it
just something that was like oh I want
to try this no no I I want to say I've
always had a admiration and a respect
for the Craft um I've always been a
supporter uh and I've always had
comedians around me as friends and you
know just haphazardly
um and and it wasn't until one of my
comedian Partners his name k du uh it
wasn't until he he just threw me on
stage out of spite you know I did that
to him yeah like 1500 people yeah so
yeah I mean dude that that that's so
uh near to me because both of us were
known for other stuff and we start doing
standup and then it's like oh well this
this guy doing standup H like ah yeah I
mean people are very very uh protective
of the art form and um I mean I I
understand it I respect it but at the
same time it's not like they have a
monopoly on laughter or something that's
that's 100% true and let's be clear too
it's only some people are protective of
it I think that it boils down to whether
people have a mentality of abundance m
or a mentality of scarcity yeah I feel
like the only people that get pissed off
are the people that like that's their
only job as a comedian but if you have
like other like lanes and Outlets people
aren't like hating on you even if that's
your only job yeah why would you hate
yeah like if you're already kind of like
solidified and on your path doing it
your way checking off your goals uh it's
the people who aren't doing that like
they ain't doing [__] you know what I'm
saying like the haters yeah well I mean
that's that's like a generic term but I
mean like the how I feel like okay so if
you have not if you have historically
ain't been [__] 17 years consecutively
yeah you know what I'm saying and you
doing the same thing trying just as hard
last year as you did this years you do
the next year and you ain't been [__]
then now or next year and you just
looking for a reason yeah of course so
this is an easy Escape it's an easy way
to say this is why it hasn't happened
for me of course because people are
taking away opportunities yeah well now
it just bro you just ain't good enough
you spotted you got it that's yeah and I
mean I tell I tell them all the time
it's a long long list of [__]
that they would have called even if they
didn't call me you know what I'm saying
you got Carrot Top PeeWee Herman you got
you know it's a lot of people man it's
not my fault you know get out there and
work harder did you get nervous going up
on stage yeah I always get nervous going
up on stage get nervous going up on
stage when you're doing music no I'm I'm
I'm abundantly certain that this going
to go phenomenally well but comedy
tripping yeah with comedy you know you
know I can't like you know I I
it's it's more of a direct connection
between you and the audience yeah you
know on stage you got the DJ you got the
music you got the microphone people's
familiarity with the music is already
going to carry you through the show for
the most part and you have hits that
helps yeah hits is the sickest music of
all
time I think it's more than just a
direct connection with the audience it's
a uh if you don't deliver the laughs you
know like they'll be excited this was my
experience you know announce Steve oh
they're excited to see me because they
know me like oh man and and everybody's
out to have a good time they're rooting
for me because they want to have a good
time they want it to go well I get on
stage there's that excitement and then
the excitement lasts for at maybe like
30 seconds and now it's my job to
deliver and if I'm not providing
entertainment which meets what people
are looking for then it can go south
real fast and that's why it makes sense
to be nervous it's also you
know people have already predetermined
their expectations of you before you
stepped on that stage they have already
predetermined that expectation of what
they
should get from the
experience and being in your presence
and the same thing for me when I step on
stage people already predetermined what
they expect from me now that I've kind
of like you know been consistent with
with with being on stage as a comedian I
kind of have added to those expectations
yeah so you know people have laughed
here and there there's enough people
who've come to my shows and left like oh
man I I didn't know what to expect but I
I liked it
uh simply because it's honest you know
what I'm saying it's honest it's not me
up here trying to pretend to be
something that I'm not talking about
things that you see that I obviously go
through and you know giving inside uh
commentary on things that you probably
read about me you know and um and
finding humor in in in some of the pain
that I
experien over the course of these years
and you know people seem to appreciate
it that's epic when when when you're out
doing comedy over the last two two years
what kind of venues are you performing
in I've done all kinds man I prefer
comedy clubs but I've done some theaters
uh I did some
Arenas um I just stand Aras yeah yeah
yeah not me on the bill the headliner
but um I just opened up for Dave
Chappelle when he came
to this Halloween
wow I've opened up for
um Mike UPS I've opened up for Kevin
hard boy there you go I did a kamic view
they brought kamic view back okay um I
think uh Kevin and Mike EPS uh executive
producers they brought it back and I I
did a 15minute set on on an episode of
Comic View um I'll go up anywhere if
they let me up S great yeah yeah that's
excellent man so I like the intimate the
small rooms better though all right yeah
uh I I think that in a comedy club with
everybody's busy eating you got the the
servers taking the orders and and all
that I just think it's distracting man I
don't mind if it's a small room but like
just the restaurant Factor kind of bums
me out there kind what do you prefer the
most I mean do you like acting do you
like doing music do you like comedy
construction you like the car business
you like I like um cuz you're I mean I
takers right yeah you were really good
in that I was actually a standin on that
for real yeah for which character um I
forget the the the blonde guy the I
remember we're doing a scene where it
was like there we're in Downtown LA and
it was like a helicopter scene we had to
run down like a a skyscraper but uh want
to say the guy's name is Christian the
one of the main guys the white dude not
Paul Walker yeah with the
H yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I did it for like a week or
two but that but that was I was like
surprised that Christ I mean your acting
was really good like how how did you
know that you were like that you had it
cuz that was a that was a big movie well
thank you uh I also produced it me and
will Packa oh [__] wow yeah um how did I
know I had it I
um my first movie was
ATL um I I I guess I work my first two
movie I worked uh with some phenomenal
directors uh my first movie was with
Chris
Robinson um and
he he kind of instilled in me kind of
how to deliver the straight face
cool dialogue he called it
um
man I can't recall it was it's a old
actor Steve McQueen he he say hey man
Steve
McQueen okay cool and I didn't know who
the hell Steve McQueen was at first so
then I went back and started looking at
him I'm like okay so he's giving it to
you with his eyes and not really doing
much else with his face and saying the
words and staying still and so I learned
that you know what I'm saying and that's
how I kind of did my delivery for ATL
and my second movie was um American
Gangster that movie was bad Washington
you know what else is badass coffee and
I've come to learn that drip coffee is
lame and pressed coffee rules it's right
man I just learned this recently and now
I'm never going back pressed coffee and
not French pressed I'm talking Arrow
pressed this is what's up man it's like
oh okay as I make my my pressed coffee
right here it's so much faster than the
whole pot I mean
dude and it's just so much better like
you got all that grit and grime with
other kinds of coffee but not this dude
not
this and this thing is the most well
reved coffee press in the world over 55
th000 fstar reviews it's unbelievable
and super affordable less than 50 bucks
plus if you go to arop
press.com steo and use the promo code
steo you get 20% off yeah it's got this
satisfying oh yeah give me that little
hiss you hear that ah yeah I love it um
So 20% off the most popular best
reviewed presser of coffee in the world
totally uh portable you can bring it
everywhere it's small it's it's useful
and it makes the best coffee they have
like competitions like World
Championships of coffee pressing with
this company and I love it I'm never
going back and you can get 20% off your
order if you go to arero press.com
that's a o p
ss.com
SLO and make sure you use the promo code
steo as well to get 20% off your order
if you're dripping you're tripping if
you're not pressing it you're blowing it
so go to Aro press.com steo for 20% off
now let's get back to it yeah yeah Scott
director for sure um I mean what's it
like acting next to somebody like Denzel
Washington who's at the top of the top
you know I mean like the [__] feels I
mean I I can't even I can't even put it
in the words what I will say is for this
scene right here where he and I were you
know uh
together uh and it was just he and I in
the scene um before we shot this scene I
was walking pacing back and forth having
you know a moment you know what I'm
saying just you know just going over my
lines and and he looked at me he said
man you
nervous and I said well kind of man just
you know making sure I don't [__] this
up he said man come here he said look
they could have had anybody else right
here doing this what you doing right I
said yeah he said but they called you
right I said yeah he said do you know
why they called you do you know what you
did to make them call you I said yeah he
said all right [__] do that thenn we
a't got no reason to
be you know and uh and that that that
was the the what he said before we shot
this scene dude that's awesome man I
loved that movie yeah and so so coming
off of those two movies going into
takers you know I just took everything
that I learned from my first two
experiences and applied it you know and
I had so many strong strong actors and
and and characters around me from uh the
late great Paul Walker to Idris Alba to
Chris Brown Hayden chrison Michael elely
you know Zoe Sal it was a lot of us um
and all I had to do is show up and
contribute that was a fun movie yeah it
was it was um see you got the you're
producing movies acting in movies with
the with all the music and then like
still the construction business
yeah we just uh we just actually my my
my first my first commercial development
is a a mix use affordable hous and
Apartment Company in Atlanta yeah we
just cut the ribbon on on on that
congratulations my girl was in bed last
night and and and uh you know we're both
just on our phones and I I I looked at
my girl and I said man we are both so
helplessly addicted to our phones it's
pathetic and she go yeah but look at
this and she's looking at at your
affordable housing project and I was
like oh man that's so killer yeah I
appreciate it but you know what I'm
saying it's uh I I kind of weaned myself
off of the self like the the Social
Media stuff man it's it's definitely uh
distracting yeah yeah yeah it's terrible
man can can you talk about the the uh
the affordable housing complex
true uh it's 140 units 143 yeah and it's
all in Atlanta yeah and you built this
with your own construction company or
you bought it and you took it over back
no no no no so I acquired the I acquired
the land and I um I dedicated it to this
project that uh I conceived or or we me
and my team collectively conceived and
and found partners and that part parip
kind of grew the capital stack grew um
it's it's private funds as well as
public
funds um and and you know so many people
uh had to have a hand in in in bringing
that Vision to a reality including the
mayor and Andre Dickens uh the former
mayor mayor kha Lans bottoms uh the
vincino group uh myself and the the the
team of supporters I have around me it's
great yeah that's right it seems like
you have the mightest touch I don't know
about that I I do some [__] up too
yeah we're only talking about the
Highlight Reel here I've done my [__]
[__] up too I mean you have your hand
in so many different pots at what age
did this Hustler mentality come about
you know what I mean fourth grade fourth
grade and you started rapping pretty
young too like was it years third grade
8 years old and what is an 8-year-old
about it man to be honest with you
growing up without a daddy having to
focus on school when you don't want to
and you know trying to find ways to to
be the man in the house when it's just
you and your mama it's a lot of pressure
yeah well you know pressure bust pipes
and make
diamonds there you go see what I'm
saying nobody's touch it's crazy what
you say pressure busts pipes and makes
diamonds yeah either or yeah dude yeah
man that's Epic the uh the car business
you still you still got that no no no no
not in the car business I I am still a
collector of cars but I'm not in the car
business how many cars would you say you
have wow
um too many man
um probably about 17
18 wow
um do you have a favorite uh probably
yeah that's not mine all of these are
very old all right all of this is very
old can you talk about uh like uh we had
T pay on the podcast and he said most
rappers don't wear their nice jewelry
out they wear the fake stuff out but
then they wait to what did he say about
like they'll do when they do shows the
fake stuff shines better in the lights I
never I've never worn a piece of fake
jry really n cuz we wanted to do a rap
song with Steve where he's just laced
out and only fake [__] yeah I've never
I've never uh I've never worn fake
jewelry authenticity is key for me yeah
you know what I mean no matter what it
was it just has to be authentic even
before I could afford jewelry if you
pull up my second album trap music I I
had like a a little Bob Marley rope it
was just like a little a little rope
with a picture of Bob Marley on it I
couldn't afford jewelry at the time you
see what I'm saying so rather than wear
some fake jewelry I wore something that
was authentic and a true representation
of you know the culture that I that I
represent right on man and so that's
your second album yeah that's my second
album just turned 20 years old this year
and now you're you got your second to
last album is that right yeah I'm
working on it yeah um I got two more
albums and then I'm out of here you're
calling it quits retiring yeah I'm doing
who yeah the the name of the second to
last album is kiss the king it is and
then the last album is called kill the
King this is true yeah dude so uh and
you and you have songs already for this
are you still in the studio making songs
definitely have songs we definitely
still in the studio Mak song you pick
and choose you're like no no no I want
this one I want that one do that one for
this one I want this to go number four
this is going to be number five well it
doesn't exactly work like that okay so
the second to last album has a vibe that
has a vibe there um and that Vibe
is uh how can I
say so that Vibe is is is a
worldly um sort of
uh communication with girls you know
communication to girls and women and you
know for for I guess for like a player
you know what I'm saying
R&B you know kind of old
school Soulful right and kill the king
is much more dramatic sort of like a
action movie okay you feel me I like
that uh yeah so what what kind of a
timeline do you see see these albums
coming out on um I might be able to I
might be able to produce them both uh
within within the year wow and are you
going to hold on to them because you're
like okay once I do this I'm done or are
you like eager to put them out I'm eager
to put them out man I'm eager to I'm
ready to you know I'm ready to I feel
like
I've already kind of evolved Beyond just
music yeah of course but but in order to
walk away I have to earn the right okay
to walk away that means I have to put an
exclamation point on this this this this
discography this this body of work that
that I've dedicated my life to uh you
don't just like leave it and just walk
away and never come back never you know
what I mean you are you going tour I'm
sure yeah I'm sure I will so it sounds
like you're pretty well thought out do
you have like the next a 5year plan a
10year plan a legacy plan you seem like
kind of guy just your life because you
already have that mapped out pretty far
in advance it seems like you're very
calculated are you like sitting there
like you know visualizing your life yes
but that vision changes yeah that vision
changes as as my experiences grow you
know what I mean uh like I just put out
my first as a director uh a couple
months ago departments yeah and so you
know with uh the success of this is now
kind of
prioritize um writing producing and
directing films you know that's cool uh
so I I I will be working on on my next
film as a director at the top of the
year next year is directing as stressful
as like making an
album you think or is it like uh is it
just fun it's different can be it can be
as stressful it depends on who you're
collaborating with yeah if you surround
yourself with people who take it as
seriously as you then you know
everybody's just committed to the task
at hand yeah dedicated to getting it
done you know if you surround yourself
with people who you know are not as is
not as focused and committed it could be
a little more stressful yeah as a
director you have like Inspirations do
you have like a a top favorite movie of
all
time well I mean you got to think about
like what type of movie you know yeah
dude movies are like food dude you don't
always want to eat
Twinkies furthermore if you were to eat
Twinkies all the time that would be a
terrible habit and I'll tell you a good
way to break a terrible habit is to
replace it with a good habit and that's
what fume is all about what's fume it's
diffusive device which flavors air it
helps people drop filthy habits which
involve like weird chemicals frankly
drugs and replace it with simply
flavored air I always have it in my
pocket because I love
it and I have a standing offer with all
of the listeners of the Wild Ride
podcast if you SE me in person you ask
me do I have my fume in my pocket and if
I don't I will make a shout out video
for you and all your buddies and
honestly there have been a bunch of
people who did ask me if I had my fume
in my pocket and I said I do I show it
to them and I say but let's make a shout
out video for your dumb little buddies
anyway because that's the kind of guy I
am now what kind of guy are you or girl
are you going to support the Wild Ride
podcast and actually take that step
towards quitting your filthy nasty habit
by going to trf nume.com that's TR r yfu
m.com
I mean if you use the promo code steo
you get 10% off your journey pack start
that journey be a good person supporting
the Wild Ride podcast and be a better
version of You by knocking off that
filthy habit so one more time go to trif
nume.com and use the promo code steo to
get 10% off your journey
pack let's get back to it yours is
Harold and mod I I ended up watching
Harold and mod too many times today yeah
you a too many
Twinkies I mean I like I like Cool Hand
Luke I like sha Shank Redemption oh
brother row I think those are my top oh
brother R is a very good one sha shank
is a very good one I haven't seen Coan
Luke yeah Coan Luke was it's it's in the
50s and 60s it's old Paul Newman but
it's like uh I just like the directing
my my dad was a a cinematographer so
like I just I I liked the cinematography
of some things but you know what I just
watched again was wargs with Jah
hell good that was a good one and
another thing I think it depends on
where you are in your life when you're
exposed to these movies so for me I
think uh probably one of my favorites
would
be boys in the hood yeah boys in the
hood
um you know
also
uh New Jack City what was that one uh uh
menace to society that men to society
was very good movie as well what was his
name uh o dog yeah o dog and Kan I there
I just saw this like thing pop up on a
theory that it was actually the same
person just his two identities oh that's
what I just I saw like I never heard I
never heard that but I do know that
odogg was supposed to be played by
Tupac wow oh really yeah that the Loren
Tate yeah that is Loren Tate yeah he and
then he was good in dead president
presidents you ever see the Dead
Presidents def was that was a really
good that's also a phenomenal same
directors I believe D what year was man
to society cuz I'm sure I watched that
when like 93 994 yeah I I'm sure I
watched it when I was in that place
having the drugs tested on me really
yeah what place did you have drugs
tested it was a place called pharmaco
LSR okay the pharmaco life science
research in Austin Texas and were
testing drugs for pigs and cows on me
what uh it was like a medical study for
money and how much would they pay you I
pay I made two grand dude and how long a
day a day no it took 12 days so 12 days
to make two grand 12 days to make two
grand plus I was living on the streets
time what the side effects made your
heart rate go super fast the idea was
that they were going to um that the pigs
and cows would have less fat be leaner
meat but if they're going to do this
then whenever anybody eats the meat that
means a trace of the drug is going to go
into the human body which means they got
to do tests they had to find out how
much the human body could handle of that
[__] so it was like a dangerous medical
study and I with the I was telling Isaac
about it the other day and he looked it
up I told Isaac there was um there were
only six people in the study it was
inpatient or outpatient it was inpatient
we we stay Stayed there more [__] up
so they 247 did anybody did any any
fatalities no fatalities one guy left
the group because one guy left the study
because uh and I remember the dude was
just drenched in sweat they wanted our
resting heart rate to be over 150 beats
a minute Jesus and um yeah and and um
yeah there were only six people in the
study because it was so dangerous and
then I was telling Isaac about this the
other day in Austin because we were in
Austin I was like man I was here D I was
living on the streets waiting to get
into this this thing and and uh I told
him all about it he looked up the drug
and he read off the internet uh very
little is known about it the only it was
only ever tested on six young healthy
males Dam and I'm like dude I was
absolutely one of those six and while I
was in there we it was January 1994
there's probably a class action lawsuit
you can do no no no no it's s waivers
I'm sure yeah for sure like sure death
of course and um they dude Isaac also
read that 80% of pork that you eat has
that [__] in it damn so so it worked
well I I
guess you're still
here you know there more it's a lot more
high blood pressure hypertension and you
know heart disease out there from things
like pork but you ever had to do any
crazy thing for money maybe the meat
Ling you know what I mean maybe that's
why you're so lean you eat a lot but you
never you stay lean yeah I don't know
man um it uh yeah it's it's crazy man I
was uh I I I did a lot of dumb things
well I mean you know on the list of dumb
things I guess that's not the dumbest
you could do you made to Grand you know
made grand and then he lost it all D I
found out that I had a I have I have a
strong
heart that's upset so uh is it true that
before you blew up became rich and
successful that that you were selling
drugs um yeah some of my misspent time
as a youth all right allegedly yeah well
no I was doing it you know you know I
mean but at the time you know that was
right in the heart of of the the the
crack epidemic now I read that you were
selling out of your you dropped out of
high school and you started selling out
of your mom's house uh I didn't
necessarily sell out of my mom mom house
I was just living at my mom house while
I was selling you know what I'm saying
it's very very very few times you know
when I'm supposed to be standing outside
and I might have came inside it might
have been in your pocket I mean no I
mean you know c a knock on my Wonder and
you know I go outside and and you know
make my money or what have you that's
kind of what like trap music was based
on right like the that kind of Lifestyle
well you know what not yes but um the
Trap is where you go to conduct business
as as a as a drugid dealer uh like there
were this set of apartments that you
know we would just go to we went there
and a group of us we were like kind of
what was it maybe eight of us eight
eight nine of us that were all around
the same age 14 to 16 17 and um that's
where we all kind of just went and sold
drugs for at least two or three years
then we began to spread out you know as
we wanted more as we wanted more from
our efforts we we kind of felt like we
had to go different places to kind of
you know what I'm saying spread out the
opportunity and while you're selling
drugs you're still working on music and
recording albums or mixtapes I don't
record no albums and mixtapes n mixtape
was the thing at the time I was
recording we call Demos mhm I was
traveling back and forth to New York uh
to Brooklyn working with a producer
named Kevin
Ryan and we were making demos and then I
started um producing myself uh paying
for my own studio time in Atlanta yeah
um yeah now back then when there was no
social media or anything like that you
literally had to go like make these CDs
and pass them out go state by
C they hadn't even made a way to burn
CDs like you know uh like it was more
commercial like you know like burning
CDs recording CDs back then that was for
commercial use for personal use you we
didn't have that we had um cassette tap
cassette tapes yeah man you ever like uh
go to the gas station cuz in Hollywood
there's people all over here like you
know hey check out my CD and buy it for
five bucks they like think like [__] it
like I'll give this guy a listen listen
you're like this is the worst [__]
[__] I've ever heard cuz we did that one
time and it was like we we we hooked the
guy up with money and we're like okay
yeah we'll listen to your music and we
listen to we're like what the [__] is
this man I have heard I have tried to
give it a shot and I've never found
anything that was I guess above par yeah
you know what I mean um do you get a lot
of guys coming up to you all the time
yeah that's like people asking you to
kick him in the nuts they ask him to
listen to
music I guess yeah similarities I got I
got this tape let me air drop it now
they can air drop you're like [__] yeah
man that's great but you know the thing
is man
um I used to go and so when my first
album dropped didn't do so well I got
all of like the promotional CDs and all
of the the the promotional items and I
had travel South Carolina Alabama North
Carolina Tennessee Florida you know I
travel places within a 3 4 Hour radius
and um I pass out my stuff and I tell
and when I sold you the CD um I would
say look I'mma sell you this CD I sit
here I smoke one with you well listen
and if you don't like it I give you your
money back and I never had to money back
that's good yeah yeah that's that's good
man are are you uh a big a big weed guy
nah not really I smoke so much in my
youth man I mean I I mean I I
occasionally I you know I hit a joint
you know if it's if I see who roll it
you know what I'm saying I can trust the
person that's passing it to me um I I
hit a joint but I don't just like wake
up and smoke all day that ain't we got
[__] to do now yeah you know yeah I
can't imagine think if you smoke all day
every day like all your life do it don't
really do nothing for me you know it
don't really it don't get me high you
know what I'm saying I don't feel like
high like when I have a drink if I had
three two three drinks I feel the the
impact yeah of my drinking but I don't I
don't really feel I feel the same when I
smoke do you drink before you go up and
do comedy yes because you're nervous
because you want to get loose no I think
probably because I probably because I
want to I want to I want to be a lot
more loose with my thoughts effortless
in my delivery that's cool yeah I've
done it sober too not to say that you
know one is I think the timing
changes the timing kind of changes when
I'm drinking I think I'm a little less
thoughtful about you know say this then
this then this you know what I'm saying
I just kind of let it flow
uh that's what I'm talking about let it
flow baby that's what everybody should
do this holiday season let it flow let
it flow let it flow and I think you know
what I'm talking about it's business
baby with ship station we let the orders
flow man the order comes in and maybe
it's because somebody wants the greatest
stocking stuff forever who doesn't want
to pull a bottle of sto's butthole
Destroyer out of their Christmas
stocking and what diard steo fan doesn't
need a steo bobblehead well I'll tell
you these products don't ship themselves
baby now we use ship station when the
order comes in the label gets printed
out and we slap it on the box put the
goods in the box and it's out the door
just as simple as that and this holiday
season this is the time man you don't
want to have to worry about how you're
getting all your orders shipped no you
want them shipped easy it brings
together all of your different platforms
you're selling on Etsy Amazon eBay your
own website all works within the one
interface and same as all the the
shipping services so to try this out to
take advantage of the holiday season you
go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
steo that's is going to get you a 60-day
risk-free hasslefree
period to try it out man to try out this
service and sell sell sell let it flow
let it flow let it flow the money just
let it flow yeah dude and again to try
this out to make ship happen this
holiday season you go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
steo for your 60-day risk-free trial
yeah dude happy holidays now let's get
back to
it a lot more like a freestyle you know
what I'm saying it's a lot less
redundant a lot a lot more comes to the
mind a lot less uh robotic maybe yeah
yeah lot less programmed I was listening
to uh Jim Carrey talk about doing
standup and he was like they they're
like you ever smoke weed before you go
up and do standup and he was like I did
it once and he's like I went up I smoked
I smoked a joint I went up on stage and
he's like I [__] murdered mured the
hardest I've ever murdered in my entire
life I [__] and he's like I got off
and he's like I can't do that because I
don't want to be dependent on this thing
yeah to like just I'd have to like smoke
and so he he only does it sober well you
know the first time I went up on stage I
had a drink in my hand so it probably I
probably just developed a dependence
right
then it's the first time the very first
time remember I told you uh so my buddy
called me up on stage coming up on stage
whether he knows it or not tip ha
that that's how he did it yeah that's
great and I had a drink in my hand when
I went up there and I just kind of you
know just I guess it then it it was sort
of like a like I I felt safe with this
drink you know and and it went well and
it went well so I guess out of habit I
just continued to do it do you remember
uh a first
joke man the first time I went up there
I don't know if I had real jokes sure
like I I was really
just I was talking about the day and the
ironic things that happen with the day
like hey
so why is it our fault that women don't
know where they want to eat when was
time to go eat why is that our fault why
is that our responsibility cuz me and my
wife have just gotten T we leaving the
house and she didn't know what she
wanted to eat like that was really
something I had just went through you
know what I mean uh then I saying why
why is it that my wife decides to get
ready like five minutes before we have
to be so oh man you know what I'm saying
like I can tell her all day hey we have
to be ready we have to be ready we have
to be ready and then five minutes she's
like okay I just got to do my hair put
my makeup on and find my shoes like yo
bro we could have did this an hour ago I
think those were the types of things
that that I was talking about 100% but
there was no punchlines it was just kind
of ironic observations yeah you know you
know what I mean yeah like we've
known for for weeks that we got to be
there this time weeks weeks
yeah weeks you wake up you tell them
don't forget this time we got to leave
and then they act like I mean it could
be 3 hours before now and another thing
this is how I can tell that my wife has
a horrible concept of time when I have
to be somewhere let's say I have to be
somewhere one p.m. and I'll get up at
10:30 and I get up and I'll start you
know brushing my teeth and taking a
shower and picking out my clothes and
then I get dressed at about 11: 11 11:30
11:20 I'm like okay about to get ready
to go she say where you going why you
leaving so early it's I'm like man it's
about to be 12:00 I got to be there at
1: say yeah it's too early to leave I
say see that's why you late everywhere
all the time what am I supposed to leave
1259 you know what I mean and she like
no you going to stop somewhere where you
stop I gu what makes you think I have
time to make a stop if I have to be
somewhere at 1:00 yeah that's how you
know that that she just has a horrible
concept of time yeah I think that's I
mean am I going to get in trouble if I
say all women are like that or I mean I
don't think you get in trouble but you
know I uh my ladies like that unless
it's a
wedding it's a wedding she takes it so
seriously yeah that's interesting yeah
wedding is something serious I've heard
something about the the the the
construct of of time being a a a a
fictional construct yeah I the the the
it's uh quantum mechanics quantum
physics suggests that time does not
exist there's no such thing as time
there's just all one moment with every
infinite possibility all simultaneously
so one life is like an entire
cycle I you know like I don't think we
we'll ever understand it problem of time
wow yeah mean what were they doing in
like the 1500s before the clock were
they just I mean well they had sunrise
and sunet like when the when the sun
sets forth on the tomorrow I'll be there
how do you how do you know like when it
gets past that tree I'll be there or
well I I can you know I can kind of tell
time if I've been
outside like all day or you know I can
tell like around I guess afternoon from
morning the sun shines a little
differently like when the sun like
between 8:00 a.m. and 12: noon the sun
is like right in your face you know what
I'm saying like you're driving and you
have to use the sun visor and then
between like 5:30 and sunset it's back
in your face again you know what I'm
saying so for that I can kind of tell
and a director taught me to to gauge
sunset uh there's finger you get fingers
in the tree line so each finger is 30
minutes so if you got three fingers from
the Sun to the tree line you got an hour
and a half you know what I'm saying I've
learned little tricks along the way that
sounds like
a sounds like you have to be shooting in
the same place yeah for that tree line
yeah you know the worst kind of yeah the
worst kind of sun is when uh when you
leave a strip club you're like oh [__]
Su y That's you know what man I haven't
had that happen to me in a long time and
I didn't know how much I missed it to
just yeah I'm sorry dud I'm sorry uh I
want to hear more about about the movie
departments yeah department so it's a
it's it's a comedy um a hood comedy uh
set in in in a set of apartments in
Atlanta um and it basically you know it
it finds the humor in the lives of these
characters that make up this community
and all of us have a little Section 8 in
us you know what I'm saying we all come
from humble beginnings so we take a
little bit of our experiences and kind
of place it in there and and uh just
deliver the a story that I don't think
any network or
any uh Film Studio would have would
would have allowed us to do without a
lot of adjustments and changes so we
just told an authentic story in a
language that only I people
speak and and this when did this come
out oh man I don't remember October
sometime I think okay are there any like
uh true stories in here from your own
experience that you put in I mean I mean
I think that yeah sprinkled in there is
is definitely some true to life
experiences in here you know um like I
had had a mailman in one of in a set
apartments that he he he was like the
cool mailman he come and buy weed from
people and really you know what I'm
saying I had uh every set Apartments
have a candy lady every set Apartments
have a mechanic that don't never fix on
no car you know every department has you
know somebody who's smoking but just as
much a part of the community as anybody
else um every departments have a a
annoying ass lease officer yeah yeah you
know every C apartment have the young
ladies who sit outside and know
everybody business and just kind of get
commentary all day I mean you know it's
a lot of things that you grew up living
through that made its way into the
apartments that's great man and and so
you're the director of it yes and and
you own it yes uh directed it wrote it
uh co-produced it with DC
youngfly um financed it and and and
casted it you know what I'm saying there
was no Cas and direct each and every
last one of these people were partners
of mine the people that I like
envisioned for these characters and uh
where where do people find this
departments foo.com d a a r t m n TS
f.com all right there there it is man um
and uh did
I did I hear like you're you're getting
ready for your next movie yes yeah yeah
it's a romantic
comedy yeah and and is that going to be
um is that going to be same deal like
you
you you're going to finance the whole
thing you're can DCT the whole thing um
I might just Finance half of this one is
it with the success it is people are
kind of throwing money at me now all
right but I want to keep some skin in
the game cuz you know I just feel like
like that offers a certain level of of
authority over over over the you know
over the creativity of the project is
the the the romantic comedy already
written are you still got to do all that
yes I'm writing it yeah we've written I
mean I so you have to convince your wife
like hey okay so might this romantic
comedy I'm going to have I mean you know
so and so be the other person well see
the funny thing about this comedy is you
know everybody is in
it like eager and excited to have sex
but nobody gets to you know what I'm
saying it's always an interruption
always something that stops yeah you
know what I'm saying um but it it it's
about the the
taboo uh the taboo things that that come
with dating and relationships
and uh it's about to switch so if you
ever a double ated with somebody you and
your buddy and you know you you you got
a girl and you got ask if they got a
friend so y'all go on a trip or and Y
and y'all like find out that you like
his girl better than you see what I'm so
you have to and everybody and they feel
the same way but they don't want to go
against the girl code y'all don't want
to you know nobody it's a awkward kind
of place to be in and so you know the
awkward nature of of those circumstances
provides a lot of Comedy okay yeah
that's fantastic the uh so so the the
distribution or or whatever like the the
hosting how how is this put together
what do you mean like the you know I'm
looking at you've got a buy now purchase
with catap like is uh did you build the
the whole thing from scratch yes we did
wow yes we did that uh it just seems it
makes sense to like do it yourself
nowadays like you don't need anybody
yeah I got uh something that I just put
out that uh that I made by myself okay I
it's a a multimedia comedy special where
I did like all this crazy jackass stuff
but I made a live comedy show out of it
and then after
each after each what his Moment by
patreon that is uh the how my project is
hosted I did my this is my third comedy
special my second one we did ourselves
and what the way that we put it together
was just a little bit clunky you know it
wasn't like uh what do you mean I mean I
don't know like
um you mean the way we filmed it or the
all the bits that we put together the
the the actual pay wall the ACT we could
we put it together ourselves we got a
dirty porn Banker to like because like
it's it was yeah rated X and so you
can't it was rated X ah that one was was
rated R this one's rated X why is it
rated X because there's
a stunt that I do would you like to see
why I'm sure I don't almost certain I
would not like to see yeah yeah there's
a there's a stunt I did where
my I'm I'm skydiving I'm in the airplane
I'm butt naked and I got to ejaculate
simultaneously at I fall out of the
airplane with another man strapped to my
back I don't I don't I'm I I'm not even
interested in hearing about that like
yeah what's with your fixation with
nakedness that's a good
question I don't know
man yeah good question and naked around
like men like you
know that's something I never understood
like you know what I'm saying like you
know Che a thong white men fine humor
and like you know slapping each other on
the nuts and you know what I'm saying
that doesn't happen around you get naked
teabagging their buddies and [__] like
that nah n n you and your friends don't
ever yeah there there's
definitely I'm sure there are like
in-house shootouts that have started it
happens once maybe maybe one time and
maybe 88 it happened and the whole house
got shot up and that's funny we found
out that wasn't a way to go yeah man I
uh good question so in any case moment
moment's a little bit more of a a
sophisticated experience they got so
it's already built so like yeah it's
already built and and and people can buy
my [__] yeah you go to the bottom PayPal
you know you see there's merch attached
to it so they can like add onto a cart
t-shirts and books and that's dope yeah
that's cool yeah it's just a very very
slick
sophisticated way for people to
distribute their own independent
projects okay and uh I I'm pretty happy
with how it's going man well
congratulations man yeah thank you dude
I appreciate that a lot man on y'all
still doing the jacket man hold up man
what' you do with that
hand yeah my hand's good
today we uh see we had a a jackass movie
come out last year okay and that that uh
went
that went really well man it's it's
crazy too talking to you like uh you
remind me a little bit of my buddy
Johnny Knoxville Johnny nville I I man
he's a cool cat he's a cool cat I don't
think I've I I I've probably met him in
passing but I really spend a lot of time
right you know around him he's great man
why what's the similarity just that
there's just uh like
just they're cool like uh cool but
there's just something about like uh the
way you speak speak a little bit the way
you smile like uh like like just a
little bit reminds me of Johnny
Knoxville I was thinking that while we
were talking there you go um but yeah
Rich damn I didn't know he'd going great
yeah wow it turn it turned out that he
had been uh dying his hair since he was
in his
20s but but it was during the pandemic
that he couldn't get to the to the hair
hairdresser person that dyed his hair
right I think he look better Gray but I
mean you know what I'm saying it brings
out a certain um Gena you know what I'm
saying he's great man he's great so um
before we let you go I do want to talk
about your uh you had a single out
singles out
with yeah it's called V yeah you got it
you did it with an artist from South
Africa yes her name is a
camo okay and the producers also from
South Africa his name is Champ and um
this uh this will be a single from Kiss
the king yes that's right and okay so so
the the video is out on uh YouTube yep
okay and
um okay when when did this come out uh
uh this came uh December 2nd all right
man did you ever hear about me trying to
rap no
okay I was fortunate enough to dodge
that H man
oh [__] no not a word not not an
utter that's good
okay that's great all right man I heard
about you in the Wu tank yeah how about
that you and Ray
Quin I don't know how you didn't see
that
coming yeah it might have been the
camine or the
we hey man listen I don't know how you
didn't see that coming bro yeah that is
uh that is perfectly fair I I uh I I I
was
drunk but uh but yeah man it it's all
good dude so so we're telling everybody
first and foremost you go to departments
44.com indeed to watch this hilarious
movie yeah set in and if you like it
please tell your friends about it man
you know what I mean if you don't like
it just shut the [__] up don't say
nothing just don't say anything I'm
going to watch that tonight appreciate
it for sure I appreciate it it's the
apartments and then the new single is
called V yeah let's get that everywhere
music streams and watch the music video
on YouTube please and and where do
people find out where you're going to be
doing comedy um well haha Mafia uh at at
the haha Mafia uh on Instagram okay um
and uh you know we pretty much post up
our dates and stuff that we had going
on and yeah we just continue to push on
through man and um the uh the the the
commercial real estate project with the
construction building oh okay so look
for the commercial real estate project
uh the the mix use development uh I
should say um we have about 18,000
square fet of retail space commercial
retail space that is uh on the ground
level and we
need a supermarket and a pharmacy so
anybody out there you know if if you're
looking to come to Atlanta and bring
your Supermarket your Pharmacy I need
you to contact me somehow I don't know
how but some find a way come to inada on
Bankhead and tell them I sent you and
because we need a supermarket and a
pharmacy it is a food desert and um
and people have to travel too far to to
feel their prescriptions well that's
great I'm glad you're doing that
yeah anything else that we want to shout
out man man I'm about to go ahead and do
my sit man thank y'all for taking the
time I appreciate yall for being
accommodating with the location too my
pleasure my pleasure we love we love
bringing this to the guest but yeah it
was an honor man thank
you can we agree that tip is the coolest
guest that we ever had I mean if you
don't agree or if you do agree go ahead
and leave a comment you know tell us who
you think is the coolest guest or that
I'm right and man what can I say to my
beloved dear street team the people who
stick around to the very end of the Wild
Ride
podcast I love you guys and if I'm
honest I'm I'm rather overwhelmed I've
been uh burning the canand at both ends
can't even say the word candle I'm
burned out baby I've been really really
going hard and um I I think I'm G to
take take a little bit of time off I'm
going to retreat to Tennessee you guys
want to go to Tennessee
yeah yeah
yes I love to check out your place dud
yeah I mean dude the bus is out there we
can record podcast on the bus yeah you
want to go to Tennessee
dog all right all right let's check it
out dude I love you guys everybody and
if you haven't seen the bucket list yet
hul ass too.com and check it out it's
[__] awesome and again I love you
thank you all
right